I guess this is the part where I make a
cliche joke about the language of
romance
jatin nuevo Tok daisuki mahal kita Mia
mas VIN okay cut cliche joke over
finished hello everyone welcome to the
Lanco cos channel and my name is Paul
today I'm going to be talking about the
Romance languages
not the language of romance but the
Romance languages why should you care
about the Romance languages well the
most important Romance languages are
French Spanish Italian Portuguese and
Romanian they are some of the most
widely spoken languages in Europe and
some of them are spoken widely around
the entire world there are 800 million
native speakers of Romance languages
around the world
that's why you should care they are a
group of languages that belong to the
italic subfamily of the indo-european
language family the italic languages are
languages originating and what is now
Italy what is the capital of Italy
yes it's Rome for answering that
question correctly you win absolutely
nothing sorry Italy italic Rome Romance
I see a connection which brings me to a
frequently asked question why are they
called the Romance languages
they're called the Romance languages
because they all developed from Latin
which was the language of the Romans and
the Roman Empire as the Roman Empire
spread throughout Western Europe the
local population in most of those areas
adopted Latin two forms of Latin were
used throughout the empire one of them
was classical Latin which was the formal
language used by the upper classes and
there was vulgar latin which was the
common everyday speech of the common day
people vulgar latin is the latin that
spread amongst the local populations of
the roman empire they called it vulgar
latin because they used to say things
like human gift
actually that's not true vulgar just
means common or vernacular overtime
vulgar latin in the different areas of
the roman empire evolved separately into
different varieties of spoken latin and
after the fall of the roman empire they
started to diverge even more and
eventually they evolved into separate
languages unlike today in those days
there was no TV no radio no universal
education to keep people anchored to the
standard form of Latin so the spoken
forms of Latin diverged quite easily
it's hard to count the number of Romance
languages in existence because they form
a dialect continuum that means that if
you draw a line from Portugal to Italy
or from southern France to northern
France any two villages along the way
would be able to understand each other
but if you move further along that line
it becomes more difficult for them to
communicate because their dialect become
more divergent so it was difficult to
determine where one language ended and
the other began but when modern
nation-states arose and free education
was introduced certain local dialects
were chosen to become standard national
languages such as Parisian French in
France and Castilian Spanish in Spain
this has caused many of the old dialects
to collapse into a smaller number of
national languages and regional
languages the main Romance languages of
today are Spanish with 410 million
native speakers Portuguese with 216
million native speakers French with 75
million native speakers Italian with 60
million native speakers and Romanian
with about 25 million native speakers I
should probably also mention Catalan
which has 4 million native speakers
Catalan is a language spoken in the
Catalonia region of Spain 42% of the
--use population or 210 million people
are Romance language speakers that's
only 26% of the total number of Romance
language speakers so where are the
others as European countries like France
Spain and Portugal colonized the world
they spread their languages to countries
all over the globe today Spanish is
spoken by 377 million people in the
Western Hemisphere where it is the
official language of 19 countries
banished is not the only language spoken
in the Western Hemisphere Portuguese is
spoken by 200 and 2.6 million people in
Brazil that makes Portuguese the
majority language in South America even
though it's only spoken in that one
country Portuguese is also spoken in
five African countries it's an official
language in Macau but it doesn't seem to
be used much anymore and some people
still use it in East Timor where it used
to be the official language as for
French it is spoken as a native language
by seven point seven million people in
Canada 10 million people in the
Caribbean it is also widely spoken as a
second language and a lingua franca in
Africa where it is spoken by 115 million
people in 31 different countries inside
Europe it is not only spoken in France
but also inside Belgium and Switzerland
unlike France Spain and Portugal Italy
started building colonies quite late in
the game so they didn't really establish
their language abroad very much it was
spoken in Libya and Somalia but now it
seems to be only spoken by a handful of
elderly people there within Europe
though Italian is spoken as a native
language in Italy and also San Marino
the Vatican and Monaco and it's also
widely spoken as a second language in
some nearby countries like Croatia
Slovenia Albania and Malta standard
Italian is based on the dialect of
Tuscan but there are numerous other
varieties of Romance speech in Italy
some of which can be considered their
own languages one example of that is
Sardinian which is spoken on the island
of Sardinia by approximately 1 million
people but these days the younger
generation doesn't seem to speak
Sardinian very much instead they learn a
mixture of sardinia and standard italian
which has kind of become a regional
dialect of standard italian another
language that has declined somewhat in
this way is Occitan which is spoken over
an area covering part of northern italy
southern france and a little bit of
spain like Sardinian Occitan is mainly
used amongst the older generations and
while young people can understand it
they don't really speak it that much
Occitan forms a dialect continuum with
the catalan language in Spain
that means that a Catalan speaker and an
ox attend speaker from nearby regions
can understand each other even though
they are speaking different languages
unlike occitan which is fading catalan
is a thriving regional language in the
spanish region of Catalonia it has four
million native speakers and five million
second language speakers there there are
several other regional languages that
are co-official with Castilian Spanish
in their respective regions in Spain
these regional languages have remained
much stronger amongst the younger
generations than the regional languages
of France and Italy have or the Romance
languages mutually intelligible well I
want all the speakers of Romance
languages to comment on that down below
and share their experiences can you
understand people when they speak other
Romance languages let us know but
generally it seems that the answer is
yes and no sometimes in certain cases
they can understand each other but only
to a certain extent and in other cases
communication is quite straightforward
from what I understand the highest
degree of mutual intelligibility is
between Spanish and Portuguese or
between Spanish and Italian or between
Italian and Romanian but sometimes that
intelligibility goes mostly in one
direction for example Portuguese
speakers can often understand Spanish
speakers very well but Spanish speakers
can't understand the Portuguese speakers
because of the complex phonology will
learning one Romance language help you
learn another one the answer is yes it
won't make it automatic or super easy
but it will help of course because all
of them come from the same Latin roots
and much of the vocabulary comes from
Latin and much of the grammatical
structure is similar and is based in
Latin so if you love learning languages
and you want to learn a language that
you can use in lots of places around the
world then one of the major Romance
languages would be a great choice so get
on it learn a Romance language a
language of love thank you for watching
the lang focus Channel be sure to leave
your comments down below especially if
you speak a Romance language tell us
your experiences alright have a good day
you